el acuerdo de lleda crea esperanza en
Sudán a pesar de que los bombardeos del
ejército sudanés en jartum continúan el
cese al fuego acordado en la capital
Saudita representa una luz al final del
túnel para muchos sudaneses La tregua
fue mediada por Arabia Saudita y por
Estados Unidos mismos que se esperan
monitoreen de cerca que tanto el
ejército como las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido respeten el alto a las
hostilidades
se trata de un acuerdo muy bueno
realmente Esperamos que se aplique sobre
el terreno y que Estados Unidos y Arabia
Saudita supervisen su aplicación
Esperamos que se consiga seguridad y
estabilidad
Naciones Unidas ha recibido
positivamente el anuncio del acuerdo
Aunque advierte que de no respetarse la
guerra podría escalar y transformar su
naturaleza de un conflicto político aún
no étnico
se han destruido vidas e infraestructura
la creciente egnización del conflicto
corre el riesgo de ampliarlo y
prolongarlo con implicaciones para la
región el alto al fuego a corto plazo
acordado puede y debe allanar el camino
a las conversaciones para un cese
duradero de las hostilidades
La tregua temporal duraría una semana
completa y en caso de respetarse sería
el lapso de paz más largo desde que
iniciaron las hostilidades entre ambos
bandos el 15 de abril